see i wonder if nature in this kind of
discussion if nature is a catalyst for
innovation or if it's a ceiling for
innovation so like
is it going to always limit us like what
you talking about silicon
is it just make it super easy to do
awesome stuff in a certain dimension but
we could still do awesome stuff in other
ways it'll just be harder or it doesn't
really set like the maximum we can do
there's a that's a good thing to that's
a good subject to discuss i guess i feel
like we need to lay a little bit more
groundwork so i want to make sure that
um
i introduced this in the context of lis
mullen's previous idea so who's lee
smolin and what kind of ideas does he
have okay lee smolin is a theoretical
physicist who
back in the late 1980s published a paper
in the early 1990s introduced this idea
of cosmological natural selection which
argues that
the universe did evolve so his paper was
called did the universe evolve and
i gave myself the liberty of titling my
paper
does cosmological selection or does
cosmological evolution select for
technology in reference to that so he
introduced that idea decades ago now he
primarily works on
quantum gravity loop quantum gravity
other approaches to
um
unifying quantum mechanics with general
relativity as you can read about in his
most recent book i believe and he's been
on your show as well
so but i i want to introduce this idea
of cosmological natural selection
because i think that is
one of the core ideas that could change
our understanding of
how the universe got here our role in it
what technology's doing here
but there's a couple more pieces that
need to be set up first so the beginning
of our universe is
largely accepted to be the big bang and
what that means is if you look back in
time by looking
far away in space you see that um
everything used to be at at one point
and it expanded away from there there
was a
era in the evolutionary process of our
universe that was called inflation and
this idea was developed primarily
by alan guth and and others andre linde
and other others in the
80s
and this idea of inflation is is
basically that when a
a singularity
uh
begins this process of of growth
there can be a a temporary stage where
it just accelerates incredibly rapidly
and based on quantum field theory this
tells us that this should produce matter
in precisely the proportions that we
find of hydrogen and helium and the big
bang lithium-2
lithium also um
and other things too so so the
predictions that come out of big bang
inflationary cosmology have stood up
extremely well to empirical verification
the cosmic microwave background
things like this so
most scientists working in the field
think that
the origin of our universe is the big
bang and i base all my thinking on that
as well
i'm just laying this out there so that
people understand
that where i'm coming from is an
extension not a replacement of
of existing well-founded ideas in a
paper i believe it was 1986 with uh alan
guth and um another author farhy they
they wrote that a a big bang i don't
remember the exact quote a big bang is
inextricably inextricably linked with a
black hole this singularity that we call
our origin
is mathematically indistinguishable from
a black hole they're they're the same
thing
and lee smolin based his thinking
on that idea i i believe i don't mean to
speak for him but this is my reading of
it so
what lee smullen will say is that
a black hole in one universe is a big
bang in another
universe and this allows us to have
progeny offspring so uh
a universe can be said to have come
before another universe
and very crucially smolin arguably
argues i
i think this is
potentially one of the great ideas of
all time that's my opinion that
when a black hole forms it's not a
classical entity it's a quantum
gravitational entity so there it is
subject to the fluctuations that are
inherent in quantum mechanics
the
the properties that what we're calling
the parameters that describe the physics
of that system are subject to slight
mutations so that the offspring universe
does not have the exact same parameters
defining its physics as its parent
universe they're close but they're a
little bit different and so now you have
a mechanism for
evolution
for natural selection so this mutation
so there's
and then if you think about the
the dna of the universe are the basic
parameters that govern its laws exactly
so so
that so what smallin said is
our universe results from an
evolutionary process that can be traced
back some he estimated 200 million
generations initially there was
something like a vacuum fluctuation that
produced
through through random chance uh a
universe that was able to reproduce just
one so now it had one offspring and then
over time it was able to make more and
more until it evolved into a highly
structured
universe with a very long lifetime with
a great deal of complexity and
importantly especially importantly for
lee smolin
stars
stars make black holes therefore we
should expect our universe to be
optimized have its physical parameters
optimized to make very large numbers of
stars because that's how you make black
holes and black holes make offspring so
we expect our the physics of our
universe to have evolved to maximize
fecundity the number of offspring and
the way lee smolin argues you do that is
through stars that the biggest ones die
in these core collapse supernova that
make a black hole and a child
okay first of all i agree with you that
this is back to our fractal view of
everything from intelligence to our
universe
that is very compelling and a very
powerful idea
that
unites the origin of life and perhaps
the origin of ideas and intelligence so
from a dawkins perspective here on earth
the evolution of those
and then the evolution of the laws of
physics
that led to us
i mean it's beautiful and then you
stacking on top of that that maybe we
are one of the offspring right okay so
before getting into
where i'd like to take that idea let me
just a little bit more groundwork there
is this concept of the multiverse and it
it can be confusing different people use
the word multiverse in different ways
in
in the
multiverse
that i think is relevant to picture when
trying to grasp lee smolin's idea
essentially every
every vacuum fluctuation can be referred
to as a universe it it it occurs it it
borrows energy from the vacuum for some
finite amount of time and it evanesces
back into
the quantum vacuum and
ideas of uh guth before that and and
andre linde with uh
eternal inflation aren't that different
that you would expect nature due to the
the quantum properties of the vacuum
which we we know exists they're they're
measurable through things like the
casimir effect and others
you know that there are these
fluctuations that are occurring what
what smallin is arguing is that there is
this extensive multiverse that we this
universe what we can
measure and interact with is not unique
in nature
it's just our residence it's it's where
we reside and there are countless
potentially infinity
other universes other entire
evolutionary trajectories that have
evolved into things like what you were
mentioning a second ago with different
parameters and different
ways of achieving complexity and
reproduction and all that stuff so it's
not that the evolutionary process
is a funnel towards this end point not
at all just like the other the
biological evolutionary process that has
occurred within our universe is not
a unique route toward achieving one
specific chosen kind of species no we we
have
extraordinary diversity around us that's
what evolution does and for any one
species like us it might feel like we're
at the center of the process we're the
destination of this process but we're
just one of the many
uh nearly infinite branches in this
process and i suspect it is exactly
infinite i mean i just can't understand
how
with this idea you can never draw a
boundary around and say no the uni the
universe i mean the multiverse has ten
to the
one quadrillion components but not
infinity i don't know that that's well
yeah i i have uh cognitively incapable
as i think all of us are and
truly understanding the concept of
infinity and the concept of nothing as
well and nothing but also the concept of
a lot is pretty difficult
i could just i can count i run out of
fingers yeah at a certain point and then
you're screwed and when you're wearing
shoes and you can't even get down to
your toes it's like
it's like a thousand fine a million is
that what and then it gets crazier and
crazier right right
so this particular so when we say
technology by the way
i mean
there's some
not to over romanticize the thing but
there is some aspect about this branch
of ours
that allows us to um for the universe to
know itself yes yes so to be to to have
like little
conscious cognitive fingers
they're able to feel
like to scratch the head right right
right uh to be able to construct e
equals m c squared and to introspect to
have to start to gain some understanding
of the laws that govern it
isn't that um
isn't that kind of uh amazing you know
okay i'm just human but
it feels like that if i were to build a
system that does this kind of thing that
involves laws of physics that evolves
life that involves intelligence that my
goal would be
to come up with things that are able to
think about itself
right aren't we kind of close to the
the the design specs the destination
we're pretty close i don't know i mean
i'm spending my career designing things
that i hope will think about themselves
so exactly you and i aren't too far
apart on that one but then maybe that
problem is a lot harder than we imagined
maybe we need to
let's not get let's not get too far
because i want to emphasize something
that
what you're saying is isn't it
fascinating that the universe evolved
something that can be conscious reflect
on itself but
lee smullin's idea didn't take us there
remember it took us to stars
lee smullen has argued
i think
right on almost every single way
that
cosmological natural selection could
lead to a universe with rich structure
and he argued that the structure the
physics of our universe is designed to
make a lot of stars so that they can
make black holes but that doesn't
explain what we're doing here in order
to in order for that to be an
explanation of us what you have to
assume is
that once you made that universe that
was capable of producing stars
life planets all these other things were
along for the ride they got lucky we're
we're kind of arising growing up in the
cracks but the universe isn't here for
us we're still kind of a fluke in that
picture and i can't i don't i don't
necessarily have like a philosophical
opposition to that stance it's just not
um
okay so
i don't think it's complete so it seems
like whatever we got going on here to
you it seems like whatever we have here
on earth
seems like a thing you might want to
select for and this whole big process
exactly so if what you are truly if your
entire evolutionary process
only cares about fecundity it only cares
about making offspring universes because
then there's going to be the most of
them in that
local region of of hyperspace which is
the set of all possible
universes let's let's say um you don't
care how those universes are made you
know they have to be made by black holes
this is what this is what inflationary
theory tells us the big bang tells us
that black holes make universes
but what if there was a technological
means to make universes
stars require a ton of matter
because they're they're not thinking
very carefully about how you make a
black hole they're just using gravity
you know
um but
if we devise technologies that can
efficiently compress matter into a
singularity
it turns out that if you can compress
about 10 kilograms into a very small
volume
that will make a black hole that is
likely highly probable to inflate into
its own offspring universe this is
according to calculations done by other
people who are professional quantum
theorists quantum field theorists and i
hope i am
grasping what they're telling me
correctly i'm somewhat of a of a
translator here but so so that's that's
the position that is particularly
intriguing to me which is that
what might have happened is that okay
this particular
branch on the vast tree of evolution
cosmological evolution now we're talking
about not biological evolution within
our universe but cosmological evolution
went through exactly the process that
elise mullin described got to the stage
where
stars were making lots of black holes
but then continued to evolve and somehow
bridged that gap and and made
intelligence and intelligence capable of
devising technologies because
technologies
in intelligent species working in
conjunction with technologies could then
produce even more more efficiently more
like faster and better and more
different then you start to have
different kind of mechanisms of mutation
perhaps all that kind of stuff and so if
you do a simple calculation that says
all right if i want to you we know
roughly how many
um
core collapse supernova supernovae have
resulted in black holes in our galaxy
since the beginning of the universe and
it's something like a billion so then
you would have to estimate that it would
be possible for a technological
civilization to produce more than a
billion black holes
with the energy and matter at their
disposal and so
one of the calculations in that paper
back of the envelope but i think
revealing nonetheless is that if you
take a
relatively um
common asteroid something that's about a
kilometer in diameter what i'm thinking
of is just
scrap material laying around in our
solar system
and break it up into 10 kilogram chunks
and turn each of those into a universe
then you would have made at least a
trillion
black holes
outpacing the star production rate by
some three orders of magnitude that's
one asteroid so now if you envision an
intelligent species that
would potentially have been devised
initially by humans but then based on
superconducting optoelectronic networks
no doubt and they go out and populate
they don't they don't have to fill the
galaxy they just have to get out to the
asteroid belt
they could potentially dramatically
outpace the rate at which stars are
producing offspring universes and then
wouldn't you expect that
that's where we came from instead of a
star yeah so you have to somehow become
masters of gravity so like or just
necessarily gravity so stars make black
holes with gravity but any force that
can
make the energy density
can compactify matter to produce a great
enough energy density can form a
singularity it doesn't it would not
likely be gravity it's the weakest force
you're more likely to use
something like the technologies that
we're developing for fusion for example
so i don't know um
the large ignition facility recently
blasted a pellet with
a hundred really bright lasers and
caused that to get dense enough to
engage in nuclear fusion so something
more like that or a tokamak with a
really hot plasma i'm not sure something
i don't know exactly how it would be
done i do like the idea that
especially just been reading a lot about
gravitational waves and you know
the fact that us humans with our
technological capabilities one of the
most impressive
uh technological accomplishments of
human history is ligo being able to
precisely detect
gravitational waves i'm
particularly um
find appealing the idea that other alien
civilizations from
very far distances communicate
with gravity with gravitational waves
because
as you become greater and greater master
of gravity which seems way out of reach
for us right now
maybe that seems like a effective way of
sending signals
especially if your job is to
manufacture black holes right
you